[Music]
well good afternoon dear friends welcome
to our program
i'd like to know
this is a question and answer program
where
those who view these programs actually
send us questions
we do the research and then insofar as
possible we try to answer the questions
according to what we find in the bible
and the spirit of prophecy
if you want to send us your questions
here's the address where you can do it
tv at some tv dot org once again tv at
some tv
org
i have with me pastor daniel miranda
associate speaker here at secrets
unsealed
and
we want to do what we always do before
we start answering questions and that is
to implore the lord's guidance
so pastor could you please pray for us
sure thank you let's pray
our gracious heavenly father we do not
dare to open our word the word of god
without your permission so
we ask that as we delve into these
questions that you may give us the
wisdom
that you may give us your spirit
to
interpret your work correctly and that
you may also make the right impressions
on people's hearts amen in the name of
jesus we pray amen amen
well uh what's our first question today
pastor so our first question comes from
andrew g
and um this question
is about the law of god
actually andrew is just 15 years old so
we're very excited to
have uh
young people watching our program
amen and his question is concerning the
laws
how am i able to differentiate in the
scriptures between the ceremonial laws
and the 10 commandments
i know the apostle paul speaks a lot
about the laws in his epistle
and i want to know
which laws he might be referring to
like in the book of colossians or
thessalonians i know this is a sensitive
topic among the christian church
many say we are not under the ten
commandments any longer or others say
we have to keep only nine
i know it was god's original plan before
creation that we follow and keep the ten
commandments i'd like to know how to
thoroughly identify which law is being
spoken of in the scriptures thanks
well this is a very very
interesting question
particularly coming from a 15 year old
yes uh and i'd like to second that idea
that we're very happy that we have a 15
year old sending questions here to our
studio amen
um
basically in the old testament there are
different kinds of laws
we have first of all uh ceremonial laws
or ritual laws
those are laws that
you know
were fulfilled
when christ came to this world you know
like the sacrifices the passover
unleavened bread uh pentecost
those were fulfilled uh in christ they
had a specific purpose right so those uh
even though they still apply in the
sense of understanding the work of
christ
they are not uh observed like in old
testament times correct uh then we also
have
uh civil laws
which are laws that govern israel as a
nation
then we also have health laws
and the health laws are binding uh all
the time because
your body is the same all the time
so if
the bible tells us for example in
leviticus 3 verse 17 that we should not
eat any flesh with blood or with fat
we know that's a health law
that
is meant to keep us healthy
and then of course we have god's moral
law the ten commandment law
um i'd like to read a statement that
ellen white
gives us here in the book patriarchs and
prophets page
where she's
commenting on the ceremonial law and the
moral law
and whether they can be distinguished
this is what she wrote there are many
who try to blend
these two systems that is the ceremonial
law and the moral law
using the texts that speak of the
ceremonial law
to prove that the moral law has been
abolished
but this is a perversion of the
scriptures
the distinction between the two systems
is broad
and clear
the ceremonial system was made up of
symbols pointing to christ to his
sacrifice and his priesthood
this ritual law with its sacrifices and
ordinances was to be performed by the
hebrews until type met anti-type in the
death of christ the lamb of god that
taketh away the sin of the world and
then she goes on to describe the moral
law
and she says that there is a clear broad
and clear distinction between the
ceremonial and the moral law very clear
i would like to
add in deuteronomy 31
verse
and 27
actually
uh verses 24 through 26 of deuteronomy
31 we see here also distinction um
oftentimes when we read colossians for
example that is the the epistle being
referred to here and thessalonians
there is this
expression that says that
uh it says let me read it
in the
colossians chapter 2
blotting out the handwritings that
that's the expression i was looking for
and then it says nailing to the cross
now there is a characteristic of that
handwriting or ordinance
and the the verse tells us that it was
contrary to us but what was the law that
was contrary to us here in deuteronomy
31 verses 24 through
it says for it was when moses had
completed writing the words of this law
in a book when they were finished that
moses commanded the levites who bore the
ark of the covenant of the lord saying
take this book of the law and put it
beside the ark of the covenant of the
lord your god that he may be
there as a witness against you
and then it says for i know your
rebellion and it goes on to say so this
is different from the love the ten
commandments because first of all
the law of the ten commandments was
inside the ark
this one is
beside the ark
moses is the one that writes this book
although it was revealed to god but the
moral law was written by god himself
with his own finger
and
thirdly the document here is a book
but
the document
in regards to the ten commandments are
stones or a rock
so
it is it is
this is not the only difference but this
is one of them
that i believe is really clear
that there were two laws yeah
specifically
in this case of ceremonial and moral law
yeah the problem many times is that the
word law
both in the old and new testament can
apply to all of the different kinds of
laws
you know the word nomus in the new
testament
is a word the apostle paul can talk
about the law of sin
he could talk about the law
you know of the ten commandments so he
can use the word law a law that works in
his members
you know where the word law means
different things according to the
context in which it's found the same in
the old testament the word torah
is a word that refers to instruction in
general terms
so
we also have to um
how would i say this we also have to be
practical in the way that we read the
scriptures
and be able to distinguish what is
temporary from what is eternal for
example you shall not commit adultery
well there's nothing ceremonial about
that yes you know that's part of the
moral law now remember the sabbath day
to keep it holy obviously that's totally
distinct from the health laws that's
distinct from the civil laws it's
distinct from the ceremonial laws
so so you have to be practical in the
way that you read the word law and you
have to read it within the context take
into account the context and another
important point is that we should look
at the law as a whole
and and the issue mainly with the law is
not the other nine commandments but the
issue here is the fourth commitment so
many people want to take the fourth
commandment out of the moral law
and that's the one they want to nail on
the cross
but the law is a unit you cannot take
one commandment out i mean james tells
us that if we keep the entire law but
then we fail in on one point
we are transgressors of the entire law
so as god is one
the law his law the expression of his
character is also one so we cannot
separate that we cannot dissect
one commandment apart from the nine
commandments all of the commandments are
important or all are part of the same
law
in fact the book of james says that he
who transgresses
is really guilty of transgressing them
all because they're all closely related
yeah you know
transgressing any of the ten
commandments is sin and the wages of sin
is death
so
you know we have to be practical in the
way that we read scripture and we need
to be sincere
we don't come to the bible to try and
prove what we believe correct we go to
the bible
to find out what god wants us to believe
and of course there are those who say
well you know the apostle paul says that
we're not under law we're under grace so
if we're under grace you know it doesn't
matter if we sin
well the fact is when you look at the
context of that verse we're not under
law but under grace the apostle paul
says shall we then sin because we're not
under love but under grace god forbid
so but but you're right when you say
that the intention is to get rid of the
fourth commandment the commandment you
shall remember the sabbath day to keep
it holy i remember joe cruz gave a good
illustration because christians say well
you know he jesus nailed all of the ten
commandments to the cross
and then he unnailed nine of them and
joe cruz used an illustration he said
that's kind of like uh amputating four
fingers that the
ten fingers of your hands and then
sewing nine of them back on
it doesn't make any sense it's either
everything or nothing
that's a good illustration
well i hope that uh we need to learn to
think in principles amen you know we
want everything spelled out you know
what can i do on sabbath what can i do
in sabbath you know we need to
take the principle of not doing our own
thing on the sabbath day we need to be
sincere say lord is this if i did this
would this be doing my own will rather
than your own will so we we can't depend
on the minister giving a long list of
do's and don'ts exactly we have to pray
to the lord and ask the lord for
guidance as to what he would consider
proper on the sabbath or not proper amen
okay now we have here another
interesting question this one comes up
every so often
and actually it's two questions
the first question is
can we pray only to god
or also to jesus
so how do we answer that question do we
pray to god the father or do we pray to
jesus
well jesus taught us
to pray to the father
in the lord's prayer here in matthew
chapter
we find
jesus's instruction
in regards to prayer
and um let me find
verse nine verse nine
in this manner
therefore pray
our father in heaven
hallowed be your name
so jesus taught us to address
the father directly
he
now we we close prayer in the name of
jesus why because jesus is the mediator
he's the channel to which we can have
access to the father
but we're taught to pray to the father
yeah
so
you know when people say dear jesus
and they begin our prayer their prayer
dear jesus
uh that's not properly biblical correct
because jesus said whenever you ask the
father in my name
that he will do yes so um the proper way
of praying then is to pray
to the father
in the name of jesus amen jesus as the
intercessor
okay now here's another question related
to this one
and what about the holy spirit why is he
not prayed to
why don't we pray to the holy spirit we
pray to the father through jesus that's
a good question why don't we pray well
the holy spirit well the holy spirit has
a part in prayer
but his part is not
answering our prayers if you will
his part is
whispering
his prayers in our souls so that we may
pray acceptably before god in the book
of romans
we find the verse
about the
the
the role of the holy spirit
in
prayer
here we read we find in romans chapter 8
verse 26 verse 26
likewise the spirit also helps in our
weaknesses
now what kind of weakness
for we do not know
what we should pray for as we ought so
that's a weakness we don't know how to
pray
but the spirit himself
makes intercession for us
with groanings which cannot be uttered
so the holy spirit makes intercession
for us with groanings which cannot be
utter we can't pray we don't know how to
pray the holy spirit intercedes in our
souls he puts in our mouths the words
that we need in order to address the
father
in other words the holy spirit tells us
how to pray to the father in the name of
jesus
exactly
so that all three of them are involved
amen in the process of prayer
but um
but we don't pray to the holy spirit the
holy spirit just as an aide in prayer
amen
okay well very good now the the last
question that we have today
is a complex question
um
do you want to share a little bit we you
know we might have to go till the next
program to finish this question but
let's frame it at least
for today
so this question from comes from
jolanda
matus
and it's a long question
it has to do with a conversation she had
with her son
in regards to last generation theology
basically the question um
has to do whether
uh if god needs us to vindicate him
and how do we explain
sanctification
in the
context of the great controversy
but the main question uh
spins around
that if god really needs us to vindicate
his character because
according to her son
if we say that we are focusing
on the plan of salvation on man and not
of god that jesus did the
vindication
this is what his argument says
but we don't have to vindicate him
because jesus already did it
yeah and you know the
the response to that
would be that
christians say of course jesus
lived a perfect life and he overcame
satan he was god
he had powers that we don't have exactly
but the idea of a last generation that
is totally victorious the purpose is not
to focus on the last generation say oh
look how holy they are how perfect they
are how wonderful they are no
it's to prove
that not only christ
could overcome
through the power of the spirit in his
life
but that the followers of jesus
can overcome and keep the law as well
and that takes away the argument that
well you know jesus was god uh you know
he had powers that we don't have uh he
had he didn't have a sinful nature like
we do
and so god is going to prove through an
entire end time generation
that
that there is a generation of people who
keep the law out of love for god even at
the risk of giving up their lives amen i
was recently reading an article
the author of this article was against
last generation theology
and he was saying
that
thinking that there will be a last
generation that will vindicate god's
character is nonsense
because
how can we say that there will be people
who are better than paul or the
you know people in the bible like moses
so they have the idea that those who
teach last generation theology are
saying that the last generation will be
better than anyone else
now what i see that
makes the difference is that the last
generation will go through a time of
trouble
that has never been
before that makes the difference and god
is going to prove
through his own righteousness working in
his people
that even in the most difficult time in
history yet they can still remain true
to god
and that proves that what god has been
saying
is right but it's not so much on what
they do is what the work that god does
through them
in a very
difficult period
of this earth which is
the time of trouble yeah the fact is
that the big quotation from the spirit
of prophecy that is at issue
is the one in christ object lessons page
69 yes where ellen wright writes that
when the character of christ is
perfectly reproduced in his people then
he will come to claim them as his own
and you know people say are you kidding
me that the character of christ can be
perfectly reproduced in his people well
that's exactly what the spirit of
prophecy is saying
i mean you just have to read ellen white
as it's written exactly and and not say
well you know but you got to take that
with a caveat and and so on
now
in romans i want to add something else
here in romans chapter
paul is dealing with
the first half of the of the chapter
actually the first eight verses
paul is dealing here with
the vindictive righteousness of god he's
saying for example that if our
unrighteousness in verse 5 demonstrates
the righteousness of god while what
shall we say if god is unjust who
inflicts wrath i speak as a man
certainly not so in other words he's
saying that because we sinned
that proves in contrast that god is
righteous and that he is good but god is
not
satisfied just
showing him his vindictive righteousness
or his justice in destroying sin and the
sinners but he wants to show something
else that is even more glorious and we
see it here in verse
but now the righteousness of god apart
from the law is revealed being
witnessed by the law and the prophet so
here there is another righteousness that
is revealed
and this righteousness is revealed so
that we might be saved
now verse four going back to
verse four he is quoting here actually
verse yeah this it is let's see if it is
quote in psalm 50 yeah he's he's quoting
psalm 51 that you may be justified in
your words and may overcome when you're
judged so god is judged god is judged
exactly and how is it that god is
justified
in his words when he's just when he's
judged well
what was david doing when he wrote this
he was confessing his sin he was
repenting he was allowing the holy
spirit to work in his heart to change
his heart to transform it and when we
allow the work of the holy spirit in our
lives to transform us then god is
justified in his words and he overcomes
when he is being judged
you know we also need to take into
account
uh that the final generation
will receive the latter reign
the fullness of holy spirit power
without measure amen
and
the purpose of the latter rain is to
mature the harvest in biblical times
purpose of the latter rain was to bring
the harvest to maturity
and
of course revelation chapter 18
is describing the time
when the holy spirit will be poured out
without limit that's the angel that
descends from heaven that the whole
earth is illuminated with his glory and
and then of course that empowers god's
people
to
uh preach with power so that those who
are still in babylon can come out and
then of course after all the faith will
have come out and joined god's remnant
people
then probation will close
and god's people will live during the
time of trouble without an intercessor
amen you know
it's kind of frustrating really
because um you know people say well you
know ellen white says that jesus is
going to
change his priestly robes to his kingly
robes
and
i say to them and uh you don't think
that's in the bible
uh how is jesus clothed today
they say well you know he's clothed as a
high priest according to the book of
hebrews so i say okay that's correct
he's closed as a priest
so how is it going to be clothed when he
comes in the clouds of heaven
and they say hmm
revelation 19 says he's comes closed as
king of kings and lord of lords so i say
sometime in between
he must have changed right he must have
changed his garments
and that's what the the standing up of
michael means in daniel chapter 12 verse
1. probation closes
all characters
are mature all characters are ripe so to
speak through the power of the latter
rain
and people are ready for translation
amen
so you know there's a lot more that we
could really say about this
i want to emphasize once again that uh
the purpose of believing in the last
generation
that will fully reflect the character of
christ is not to focus on how great they
are
it's christ in you the hope of glory
it's christ working in them
uh you know if we could just maybe read
matthew chapter five
there you have the principle
matthew chapter five i like that you're
making that emphasis because one of the
accusations is that we are putting
uh men as the center on this
right and we're not and we're not
exactly you know because ultimately
take for example moses when he came down
from the mount and his face was shining
well
was the honor and the glory for moses no
no his face was shining because he had
been printed in the presence of the lord
so the end time generation their
character is going to shine but it's not
them amen it's god who has done it in
them exactly uh yeah in matthew chapter
and verse 14 it says you are the light
of the world
a city that is set on a hill cannot be
hidden
nor do they light a lamp
and put it under a basket
but on a lamp stand and it gives light
to all who are in the house
now comes the key verse
let your light
so that's our light
but it not doesn't come from us
let your light
so shine before men
that they may see
your good works
and glorify your father in heaven amen
so there is something important in us
revealing in our works in our lifestyle
the glory of god but the glory is not
for us because it says that they may see
your good works
and glorify your father who is in heaven
amen so we always need to keep that
particular focus
and this is the first angel's message
yes it is dear god and give glory to him
glory to him yeah this is
one way or this is how we give glory to
god yeah
so
ultimately
uh even though we believe that uh god's
people will reflect fully the character
of christ
the glory is not for god's people amen
the glory is for christ because christ
is the one who is shining in them you
know i've used this illustration before
but i'll use it again you know the sun
shines
on the moon and the moon reflects the
light of the sun to the earth
the glory isn't for the moon exactly you
know we go out and we look at the moon
we say oh the moon is so romantic so
beautiful tonight but that's not true
because the moon is ugly
but when the light of us the sun shines
on the moon it's reflected to the earth
and so
when the light of christ's character
shines on us
then we reflect that light to others in
the darkness of this world amen the
glory is not for the moon the glory is
for the son
amen
well time flies
uh we're right about at the end of our
program i want to remind you
uh to please send your questions to the
following address tv at some tv dot org
once again tv at some tv dot org
and we'll do everything possible to
do the research and answer your question
that is if it's not a mystery that
cannot be answered so once again thank
you for joining us may god bless you and
keep you in his care
and uh on behalf of pastor miranda and
myself thank you for joining us god
bless you
and we hope to see you the next time
[Music]
you